wait hold up should we close it on this
ninja trying to slice bread oh yeah that
shit's really funny let's [ __ ] let's
on let me get this real quick entertain
the people so yeah I guess and he also
the way slice the avocado
I haven't haven't this dude does not
know how to do anything but game I I
have not seen this clip so this will be
a [ __ ] this will be a truly Tyler if
you're watching this it's on I still
have your merch dude I still love you
man I wanted to go get a shirt to go to
the [ __ ] gym and I thought was a
workout shirt all my others will work I
grabbed it I'm like getting ready it's
inside out I flip it inside out I throw
it on I'm like oh damn I can't where
there's already of the boxes yeah at
this point I don't think I know how to
cut this the way I think I need to do I
caught it from a side at this point like
do I leave it bread maybe normal size
slices imagine it like holy [ __ ]
bro you can see the hesitate this full
want to talk [ __ ] about NFL kickers and
you can't come
you can't cut bread dawg I'd love to see
you kick a football for [ __ ] sake man
I don't [ __ ] you dude crazy 90 building
in fortnight but you can't cut it
[ __ ] slice of bread cuz that's why
dude the best part is the next one look
at the next one look at the nice white
you just scroll down oh it's over this
oh damn oh damn he just went right
through it
he just farmed that [ __ ] just was he
fruiting injured that [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] crazy to me
man someone made a fruit ninja upon
this is hilarious bro I look weight and
I love this moment of hesitation like
right here where he goes like he's like
oh wait for a way for a way for right
here wait he goes just like to slice
isn't he goes you know what I'm just
gonna go for it
just cuts it diagonally rows it on the
[ __ ] ground
is that how you stab instead like a
sawing it hidden it like a what are you
doing like I'm cutting you said to
normal sized pieces right like a like a
bandsaw machine what are you doing bro
what are you doing
[ __ ] you know I love I don't know why
the avocado thing [ __ ] gets me so
hard no because it's just [ __ ]
unconventional as hell just those seeds
are hard to it bro you gotta like push
don't underestimate his strength bro
what's the next one I mean just yeah
this face it's like okay got it
whole low so now what do I do
god damn dude so good crazy
you